Apple is facing new pressure to help
curb what's being called children and
teens addiction to its smartphones to
influential investors are asking the
tech giant to make changes to its
software so parents can limit their
children's phone use a survey last year
found 58% worried about the impact of
social media on their child's physical
and mental health
and awareness here with the investors
push for change and a big news good
morning viana much like you can set your
TV to restrict what your kids watch well
now leading wall street activists
believe they can profit by asking Apple
to apply the same concept to its
smartphones and while Apple does offer
features that give parents some control
over their phones iPhones their kids
iPhones critics say it's not enough like
all kids they are glued to their
smartphones as much as possible when
Mark love noticed his children spending
too much time on their smartphones he
created this a wooden box to restrict
technology during certain hours for 20
minutes or an hour or whatever they're
not in sight love has sold more than 12
hundred boxes worldwide but despite its
popularity he doesn't think it's an
end-all solution I really hope that a
company like Apple or Google can find a
way out or another path love is not
alone in a letter sent to Apple two of
the company's major investors Jana
Partners and the California State
Teachers Retirement System say there's a
clear need for Apple to offer parents
more choices and tools to help them
ensure that young consumers are using
your products in an optimal manner Wall
Street Journal reporter David monoid
says the shareholders call-to-action is
to protect Apple's bottom line from
backlash the way that Jana would hope it
works is Apple does respond Apple says
we're well aware of this is could be an
issue we are going to tweak the phone
we're gonna make it the best phone you
can buy your kids more than half of
parents surveyed say their child is
attached to their phone or tablet
further studies showed that screen time
is associated with higher levels of
obesity shorter attention spans and
higher rates of depression our teams
have been hard at work
for years Tim Cook has talked about
corporate social responsibility as
Apple's CEO but boa noite says more
pressure on tech companies to become
better corporate citizens won't happen
unless investors pile on in order for
Janna and CalSTRS to kind of get their
way they're gonna need a lot of other
investors and Apple to stand up and say
we think this is serious well these two
investment groups together control only
about a two billion dollar stake of
Apple's nearly nine hundred billion
dollar market value according to The
Wall Street Journal however that's not
stopping them from also asking Apple to
study the impact of excessive phone use
on mental health Apple did not respond
to our request for comment but for a lot
of parents this is an obvious issue now
and will be for some time because our
lives yeah Thanks good thank you thanks
Anna